Well in many of the animal groups that
we're looking at,
you,
I mentioned aunts and that was sort of
special genetics of closeness,
so we can exclude them for now.
But even when we look at selfish
organisms like the fixed,
you know,
they're all locusts,
they've evolved to lift with an
incredibly large troops and incredibly
large societies.
Now we humans happened,
you know,
with food into these large cities.
No,
but that's not actually how we evolved.
And so we don't have sort of specific
rules to optimize our situation here.
And further more,
you know,
I'm mode of communication,
verbal communication and written
communication is Israel to be slow
compared to the sort of the mass media
and the all of the information that we
have now.
So there's some sort of fascinating,
uh,
challenges from a biological perspective
to the,
to our societies.
Um,
but what we do find is that people are
good at learning how to behave in
crates.
For example,
if you were to take people from,
I don't know,
the central of America who've never been
to a large city and pop them in the
middle of Manhattan,
and alternately would this be a sort of
cultural shock,
we would actually be difficult for them
to behave within these crates.
These are sort of learnt behaviors that
you sort of try things out and you
eventually kind of optimize how to
behave within these environments.
And when we film and we track people
within crites,
what sort of astonishes me is high
predictable from a statistical
perspective,
how predictable crowds are.
And so each individual,
we can't necessarily predict whether
you're going to go left or right,
but when we start getting large groups
of individuals,
we can predict properties like how many
lanes will form or you know,
what certain times a day,
who,
who will generally tend to move where.
Um,
and we can also make predictions about
congestion in these environments and so
forth.
[inaudible].